Welcome back everyone this is my video about
the hidden two face easter eggs during the
batman movie post-credits scene that some of
you have been asking me about it's hidden inside
the riddler's final secret viral post that you
can only see if you actually go to his special
rataalata website in real life after the movie
came out last week the special new easter egg
did not exist before last week so we'll break it
all down it contains a bunch of different easter
eggs two-face is just one of the biggest new
things buried in the newest teaser so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos and real quick shout out to my
friends at magic spoon who asked to sponsor this
video magic spoon makes all those amazing tasting
cereals that you remember from your childhood
the ones that were loaded up on sugar and candy
flavoring only magic spoon took all those great
tasting candy cereals and made healthy versions
0 grams of sugar 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving they're keto
safe gluten free grain free soy free lactose free
if you're on any specific dietary plans they sent
me this giant crate with a whole bunch of their
flavors they have so many flavors they're all good
but my favorites right now are the frosted ones
and the oatmeal cookie ones i'll put a link for
their website in the description below you can
click it and get their variety pack sampler and be
sure to use the promo code that they gave me and
get five dollars off any order from their website
the promo code is magicspoon.com emergencyawesome
they're so confident that this cereal is the
superior s-tier cereal that they even offer 100
money-back guarantee refund on your purchases
so be sure to check it out don't eat breakfast
like a wild animal anymore eat something good
and be sure to use my promo code to get
that discount link in the description below
but big spoiler warning for the batman movie
if you have not seen it we'll be talking about
the ending in the post-credits scene during the
ending of the batman movie at arkham asylum the
riddler watches as batman saves the majority of
all the people of the election thwarting his plan
in barry kyohan's new version of the joker is
revealed to be in the cell next to his mat reeves
confirmed it he is supposed to be the joker he's
not two face the actual two face easter egg comes
a little bit later there were just a lot of people
that were confused about who it was supposed to be
but the hyena laugh at the end and all the talk
about being a clown was meant to be very on the
nose references to him being the joker he offers
the riddler some consolation saying that batman
reigned on his parade but gotham loves a comeback
giving him a riddle of his own riddle me this
using the trademark riddler catchphrase offering
friendship to the riddler just using a big joker
riddler team up according to matt reeves the cover
in the batman arkham hbo series so you don't have
to wait till the sequel movie like three or four
years to get more of this new version the joker
he's not technically the joker yet he hasn't
started calling himself that but he does make
a lot of references to being thought of as a clown
by the people of gotham and being feared by gotham
and says maybe it's not so bad being a clown
very on the nose like i said but the big two-face
easter egg is actually part of the larger arkham
asylum easter eggs that are in the post-credits
scene with the riddler's final riddle his final
message on that rataalata website some of you
probably spotted this if you visited the website
after the movie came out so the post-credits scene
is meant to be a teaser for the secret riddler
video that he supposedly recorded at some point in
the future like you thought that the last riddle
was the one he gave to batman what's black and
blue and dead all over you but this post-credits
scene is meant to be like a secret riddle that he
supposedly recorded at some point in the future
implying that he will either break out or he
recorded it secretly and just didn't tell batman
during the post-credits scene the text pops up
as if someone has visited the website after the
events of the movie and they're queuing up this
new video to watch like the goodbye text with the
question mark flashes and you hear the riddler's
heavy breathing and then it cuts to black but
that's not the end of it the post credit scene is
also meant to be a teaser to get you to actually
visit the real life rataalata website that warner
brothers created for the movie that's right it's a
thing in real life it's a website you can go visit
when you visit it it boots up like this and you
see all this text scrolling the big question
mark here it scrolls through a lot of dos-like
prompts and coded messages then it asks you to
click at the text up at the top and when you do it
sends you to this new riddler cipher like the ones
that he was leaving for batman and decoded this
is what the cipher says you think i'm finnish
but perhaps you don't know the full truth every
ending is a new beginning something is coming
but here's the thing that's not even the end of
it the riddler has more teasers and easter eggs
hidden in this rataalata website if you remember
when the website was scrolling through all these
texts and numbers here the numbers themselves are
meant to be really big easter eggs for things in
the movie and teasers for the next big part of
the story getting to the two-face and the arkham
asylum of it all so the number 2705 1939 is a
reference to detective comics number 27 released
in may 1939 which was the very first appearance
of batman and gordon in the comics then the number
one three 1940 is a reference to batman number
one from 1940 which was the first appearance of
catwoman in joker in the comics the number 5812
1941 is a reference to the first appearance of
penguin detective comics number 58 from december
1941 the number 140 10 1948 is a reference to
detective comics number 140 in october 1948
which was the first appearance of the riddler
the number 405 3 1987 is a reference to batman
number 405 from 1987 which is the first appearance
of carmine falcone the number 16 for 1943 is a
reference to batman number 16 from 1943 which
is the first appearance of alfred in the comics
then the number 3 4 20 22 is a reference to the
batman movie's release date in real life march
4th 2022 and the last number is the real big one
258 10 1974 is a reference to batman number 258
from 1974 which was an issue all about two-face
breaking out of arkham asylum and it was also the
first appearance of arkham asylum in the comics
so all these post-credits scene easter eggs
from brought to allata taken into context
in the riddler's message something is coming is
meant to be a reference to the arkham asylum hbo
series the next part of the story where we'll see
more villains appear in arkham asylum and them
introducing a version of harvey dent the reason
why it makes so much sense that matt reese would
do a version of too face not only is he a really
iconic batman villain but also he's a huge part of
batman the long halloween which heavily inspired
the movie there were a lot of scenes directly
ripped out of the long halloween story like batman
vs catwoman the backstory between carmine falcone
and thomas wayne about him saving his life also
the story about catwoman believing that her father
was carmine falcone all directly taken out of
the long halloween but the whole killer storyline
revolves around two-face it's his wife who is the
holiday killer going around killing all these mob
members to get revenge long halloween is also
basically a two face origin story like he starts
out being harvey dent and becomes two face by
the end of the story now because matt reeves
was hyping up doing so many batman villain origin
stories that was his big reason for setting this
during batman year two he's not going to introduce
him as two-face when we see him for the first
time he'll start his harvey dent and then slowly
become a version of two-face we just watched the
riddler kill gil coulson he was the last district
attorney harvey dent is the district attorney when
he becomes two-face now that there's a vacancy in
that job we can actually see him fill that role
through the next part of the story and into the
sequel movies and then slowly eventually become a
version of two-face it's the exact same thing with
gordon eventually becoming the police commissioner
pete savage the old commissioner was killed by
the riddler and even though gordon already had
another police captain above him in the movie who
took over for pete savage after his death police
commissioners are actually elected or appointed
by the local government so just because gordon
has superiors within the gotham city pd above
him he can still be elected commissioner in
the sequel movies or maybe they'll wait
till later in the franchise to do that
they kind of took that path during the dark
knight trilogy harvey dent was introduced
became two-face in that sequel movie and that's
also around the same time that that version of
gordon was appointed police commissioner i have
seen some casting rumors on websites the past
couple days about them going after oscar isaac
as a new version of two-face in this batman movie
universe with robert pattinson but for right
now those are just rumors most of you will
remember oscar isaac is currently playing moon
knight for marvel and he's going to be crossing
over with a bunch of other future marvel movies
and future avengers movies so he is pretty busy
he's an amazing actor though so he'd be a huge
get for dc as a version of twoface i feel like he
could crush it as two face sidenote i will be doing
full episode videos for moonlight when it starts
later this month too you don't have to wait that
long for more moon knight trailer footage either
but post all your two-face casting picks in the
comments below who do you want to play this new
version of two-face in the robert pattinson batman
movies some of you may remember a long time ago
that billy d williams inside the tim burton batman
movies was going to become a version of two face
had tim burton and michael keaton stuck around to
do another movie together he was harvey dent in
that first batman movie but they never really did
two-face in batman returns so i think they were
saving that for the third movie had they done it
because they did do a version of two-face but it
wound up being tommy lee jones obviously that was
the joel schumacher era of batman so it was way
over the top even though i do have a soft spot for
jim carrey's version of the riddler in tommy lee
jones version of two face the funny stories about
the two of them trying to get along behind the
scenes are almost as entertaining as the actual
movie itself tommy lee jones apparently could not
stand jim carrey which sounds very on brand for
tommy lee jones i've got a couple other batman
videos that i'm working on this week make sure to
go see the movie if you haven't seen it and you're
just watching these videos just to get all the
easter eggs congratulations drake brunette you're
the giveaway winner for my last big batman video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my batman movie ending scene the joker
the post credit scene and click here for my full
breakdown of the batman movie with all the easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!